what's going on everyone Ian Hartz here
on behalf of PFF welcome to another week
and be our fantasy got some week one
does that we're not exactly too worried
about to talk about in a bit but first
do you guys see this maybe the single
worst fantasy football lineup of all
time like I am so sorry to one Dylan
Jackson but thank you Dylan for sharing
this with the world because just truly
from start to bottom and we're showing
it now on screen just an absolute
atrocity from again the quarterback all
the way to the kicker to start Dak
Prescott and get 53 yards in a pick I
know he got hurt guys and that's really
unfortunate for the Cowboys down the
road but even before that injury Dak was
playing like it was freaking 2018 all
over again with no Amari Cooper yet in
business just a completely pitiful
showing from the Cowboys offense that
remember was the number one scoring
offense in the league all the way back
in 2021 literally last year can't forget
about Naji Harris the high scorer the
high scorer on this team was Naji Harris
with 10.6 fantasy points he got injured
at the end of the game Elijah Mitchell
41 yards was looking good he got injured
Alan Robinson might as well have been
injured because he was ghosting that
entire Thursday night just one reception
for 12 yards after how many off-season
fluff pieces about the route tree and
how everything was going to open up for
Robinson and Sean mcveigh's offense and
how it was all naggy's fault in Chicago
at least for one week it was not also
got T Higgins concussed he only played
about a half Kyle Pitts he did not get
injured he still only had two catches
for 19 yards in a game that rather
inexplicably saw the Falcons actually
keep Pace with the Saints until the very
end can't forget about CD land having
that DAC in cd-lam stack gets you
legitimately fewer than four total
points that hurts that's a tough one to
recover for from I am not sure how Dylan
has been sleeping this week but I would
not be going well two of the three
highest scorers in the lineup was the
defense and the kicker even those spots
aren't completely removed from the
comedy of the situation though the
Eagles defense had a pick six and they
still managed to only score five fantasy
points that is so hard everyone to give
up 35 points to the Lions obviously not
ideal there and even the kicker here
just don't get a charger kicker how many
times do we have to watch the Chargers
to know that they're going to do charger
things they did get the dub last week
but Dustin Hopkins still just one for
two on the field goals so Dak Naji
Mitchell hey Rob Higgins Pitts CD Eagles
and Hopkins tough day Dylan but you know
what just one week we still got plenty
more to go so with that in mind everyone
this is BR fantasy presented by State
Farm thanks as always for tuning in we
will be back here every Thursday at 5 00
PM Eastern to break down the happenings
of the week and we'll get to plenty of
your questions throughout the show but
first want to try to calm some nerves
about some Duds in week one remember
it's an 18-week season 17 weeks if we're
just going from the fantasy side of
things and guys are going to have ups
and downs it's important to really try
to discern the difference between
what guys had down Wings because their
usage isn't what we thought it was for
example cam makers he touched the ball
three times he had zero yards that's
very problematic other players had the
really good uses that we're looking for
it was just unlucky it was a 60 Minute
sample like football in and of itself
compared to any other sport is already
going to be a smaller sample just by
virtue of it only being a set now 17
Game season let's not get too carried
away over one week so with that said
guys the first player that based on
their usage again that we should not be
worrying about is going to be Alvin
Kamara with the New Orleans Saints now
not completely in the in the clear for
week two because he does have this rib
injury now that he is dealing with and
wasn't able to practice on Thursday we
did see the Saints accordingly signed
old friend latavius Murray to the
practice squad so if Kamara is going to
be sidelined for a week or two so be it
we did have head coach Dennis Allen
already tell us though that they don't
consider the injury to be overly serious
so not expecting it to be a long-term
issue for Alvin Kamara and with that
said once he's back guys he's gonna be
just fine is it gonna be you know Drew
Brees is catching 80 90 passes all over
again maybe not only had four Targets in
week one and Jameis Winston fifth
highest average Target depth of the week
we've all watched James enough that
dude's going to air the ball out to his
heart's desire maybe not checking it
down quite as much between I'm not
checking it down quite as much as uh you
know old man Drew Brees used to be doing
back in the day but we saw this happen
last year remember Jameis about six or
seven games before he actually tore his
ACL and that put Alvin Kamar last season
on Pace for 313 carries so this is a
situation where maybe this isn't the
same old album Kamara as it passed in
terms of catching exactly 83 passes
every single season seemingly with that
said before last year he had never even
cleared 194 carries the Saints know who
their best offensive player is his name
is Alvin Kamara once he is healthy he
will go back to being an upside rb1 more
weeks than not just by pure volume
appreciate all you guys in the chat send
in your questions throughout the show
after we get through some of these
players I'll definitely be getting more
and more into your start sets or
whatever else so from at Adrian white
Palm or Pollard or McKenzie and your
Flex gotta go with Josh Palmer right now
Keenan Allen confirmed out Tony Pollard
yes pretty decent usage in week one but
this cowboys offense any close start
sick questions I'm taking the other guy
as long as Dak Prescott is sidelined
Isaiah McKenzie unfortunately splitting
snaps with Jameson Crowder right now
from at Jimmy is Rexburg had a good
start at the flex guys the Rexburg had
usage if if we looked at just Rexburg
heads usage crossed out the name Rex
Burkhead or just covered it up we'd be
talking about a legitimate rb1 I mean
the numbers he was able to actually put
up last week 72 percent snap 61 Route
rate 14 carries and seven targets if you
heard me at the top of the show one of
only 10 running backs with at least a 70
route rate or snap rate excuse me in
week one so it was just one week still
32 years old I'm not expecting Rex to
get this workload everything single week
out there but still quality rb3 that you
shouldn't be afraid to plug in your
lineup just realize this is still a
pretty bad offense not expecting them to
score a lot and last week Pierce and Rex
Burkett they had 77 rushing yards they
had 87 rushing yards after contact on
average these guys were getting hit
behind the line of scrimmage tough to do
much with that
from cxl are we starting and trusting
Damian Pierce no good you know pretty
handy having the Burkhead Damian Pierce
questions right next to each other don't
cut Damian Pierce this is the two back
backfield that's fine we can live with
two running back committees in the year
2022 there's only so many true you know
one down workhorses left so even though
we didn't get the exact uses we wanted
from Damian Pearson this applies to cam
makers as well each is only one injury
away from being the guy in the backfield
I get it you didn't draft these guys in
round five to be a high-end handcuff or
anything like that but let's not panic
one injury away or maybe just take over
away from being firmly back on the
fantasy map and you would hate to be the
guy that cut him a week before that from
tlam wavy Julio or Dotson keep an eye on
Julio's injury I'm not so sure if it's a
little bit of rest involved or if it's
an actual knee issue as long as Julio is
good to go we can start treating him as
an upside wide receiver three fun note
from Ian Rappaport after that game two
of Julio's top three game speed times
since 2020 were recorded in that Sunday
night game because the Cowboys they got
him two reverses he looked absolutely
like Julio in that game get him in
starting lineups of all shapes and sizes
as long as he is healthy enough to suit
up from the Villa who do I go with
between James Robinson etn or Dobbins
it's James Robinson right now how about
that modern science Achilles comes back
and looks better than ever I know Acres
I know Marlon Mack I know some of these
other guys haven't looked as good James
Robinson looked good last week and it
was still close between him and etn
legit 50 50 snap split between the guys
but Robinson with the 13 combined
carries and targets for now he deserves
a slight lead over etn once again though
two running back backfield don't be
cutting times with etn just yet either
finally before we get to our next guy DJ
what's up with Renfro Renfro is fine
he's still the number two wide receiver
cemented in Vegas what happened with
Renfro Davante Adams went off it's the
same thing that happened with Devonte
Smith in Philly this is where we want to
be careful about over reacting to week
one just because they had a down week
isn't the end of the world everyone's
going to have down weeks at some point
you got to make sure the underlying
usage is fine for Renfro it is
all right guys another player whose
underlying usage is more than fine just
had a bad week one it's Chase Edmonds if
there is a running back that you should
really consider buying low on right now
it is Chase Edmonds if you look at his
usage last week compared to some other
running backs that we just couldn't be
less worried about fantastic 64 snaps 57
route rate for Chase Edmonds had the 12
carries and four targets I get it it
didn't go super well but look at those
numbers guys 64 snaps and 57 routes
those are both higher than what Austin
Eckler put on the table those are higher
than album Kamara hired Antonio Gibson
even higher than Cordero Patterson the
role that chase Edmonds had in week one
was to roll that awesome neckler usually
has and it's a role that's made him an
upside rb1 for the better part of the
past two seasons so when we have someone
like Chase Edmonds in a game where the
Dolphins were beaten up on the Patriots
throughout that like this was actually
not the game script where we would have
expected Chase Edmonds to have one of
his best performances we've had
questions if he is really going to be
the early down guy with rahimosa there
maybe miles Gaskin would be involved
South in awkward Sony Michelle was on
the team we did not know what this Mike
McDaniel offense was going to look like
until we finally saw it but once we did
two running back committee with Edmonds
clearly as the lead back across all
situations like this was not a situation
where we were expecting Edmonds
necessarily be the lead early down back
ahead of Raheem mostert but he was so
now looking ahead at this week facing
the Ravens not the easiest matchup in
the world but honestly the fact that the
Ravens are three and a half Point
favorites in this one could be great
news here for Chase Edmonds because we
want them to be playing from behind
whose two are gonna be throwing those
check Downs to chase admin so another
low-key positive about this situation to
a he doesn't run all right he's not
immobile like I think
I wouldn't quite compare him to Russell
Wilson but he moves fine enough in the
pocket but he just doesn't take off and
run he has never rushed for 50 yards in
a game even going back to his time at
Alabama so in the NFL when we see guys
like Lamar Jackson Josh Allen Jalen
hurts we don't usually see these great
fantasy running backs attached to the
Dual threat quarterbacks because the
Dual threat quarterbacks they become a
part of the Russian committee near the
goal line and they usually scramble
instead of checking it down that's why
album Kamara caused so many passes from
Drew Brees over the years so Edmonds is
in an offense that's featuring him they
look good in the new Mike McDaniel
scheme and he has a quarterback that
should be more than willing to check him
the ball down so I have Chase Evans this
week as my rb16 ahead of guys like
Antonio Gibson Daryl Henderson Cordero
Patterson David Montgomery and more so
final point from the Miami Dolphins
before I get to some more chat questions
really encouraging stuff from Mike
McDaniel in his first game in Miami so
one of the cool things we like to look
at behind the scenes of PFF is how often
teams use shift or motion before the
snap obviously can confuse things for
defenses and just historically the
smarter the better offenses usually
utilize a lot of shift in motion last
year the number one offense in the
league and this was the San Francisco
49ers after week one the Miami Dolphins
ranked second a good 16 percentage
points higher than they were last season
so Tyree killed Jalen waddle flying over
the field defense is looking one way
looking the other don't be surprised if
Chase Edmonds is taking advantage of
some of that confusion and busts a big
place soon
all right chat from Jaden Hester can't
CD land be trusted CD lamb unfortunately
is not going to be the wide receiver
upside wide receiver one that we drafted
him to be but this is another situation
like some of those running backs we
talked about let's just adjust our
expectations let's not rage drop or rage
bench anyone here if you want to move CD
from your you know fantasy wide receiver
2 spot put them in the flex and try to
send a message to him okay I get it but
just in terms of pure rankings I have cd
Lam as my wide receiver 15. you can bump
them down you know some of my co-workers
wide receiver 20. he's in that range now
but guys like Brandon Cooks like Terry
McLaren like maybe Deontay Johnson out
there in Pittsburgh still an alpha wide
receiver one who else is going to be
catching passes in Dallas Noah Brown
Dennis Houston did we even know who this
guy was this time last week see the lamb
is still cemented as a number one
receiver unfortunately this offense is
looking more like one of the League's
worst as opposed to the League's best
which it was last year at least in terms
of scoring points per game so cdlam it
sucks adjust your expectations but he
should still be in the overall majority
of starting lineup apps
from Timmy Mayer Hawkinson or Gerald
Everett still going with TJ Hawkinson it
was encouraging uh stuff from Everett
last week he was able to score that
touchdown the problem is that they
actually played Trey mckitty and Richard
Rogers alongside Gerald average here so
for me Gerald Everett is actually kind
of like a slightly cheaper just lesser
owned version of Dawson Knox where we
don't have as quite of elite usage as
guys like Hawkinson Dallas Goddard
Dalton scholtab that's why they're in an
upper tier but if we are going to gamble
on tight ends that don't have the best
usage in the world they might as well be
attached to guys like Josh Allen and
Justin Herbert
from dakins Drake London or Curtis
Samuel and non-ppr I'm gonna be going
with Drake London here he was out there
he looked healthy and with that in mind
guys how about that Falcons offense
Marcus Mariota actually doing the thing
uh over these last two appearances he's
had first of all last week and then he
had to extend appearance with the
Raiders so it's been a couple years you
know we got guys like Mariota James Gino
Smith now partying like they were kind
of supposed to be doing about five times
about five years ago better late than
never though don't be afraid to fire up
Drake London as a low tier wide receiver
three for the rest of the season from
e-whizzle how do I feel about Clyde
Edwards Hilaire on the one hand a lot of
Isaiah pacheco's production was garbage
time I don't expect him to actually lead
the backfield on carries during any
given week on the other hand we still
did see Jared McKinnon working ahead of
Clyde Edward zillaire and I said it
before guys I'll say it again we can
live with two running back committees in
fantasy football three or four is when
things get complicated so looking at the
Chiefs last week Clyde actually played
the second most snaps on the team he was
at 36 percent Derek was actually out
there on the field more so yeah Clyde
got the two receiving touchdowns pretty
much walk-ins and hey they were design
plays Clyde Edwards Lair is going to get
his in the Chiefs offense because
they're the Chiefs offense and Patrick
Mahomes is a freaking alien that was put
on this plan to score fantasy points and
real life points as well but
unfortunately what Clyde did not see the
sort of usage take over where all of a
sudden he's someone we need to start
every single week for me Clyde Edward
zillaire someone that's going to be on
that rb2 rb3 borderline this week I have
him rb27 I would play him ahead of the
Jaguars backs ahead of the Patriots
backs ahead the Jets backs but guys like
Jeff Wilson like miles Sanders liked
even Josh Jacobs and Ezekiel Elliott I'm
far more convinced in their week to week
role than Clyde at this point
from Jimmy kaser what do I think of
taysom Hill as a tight end quarterback
deep leagues deep bench don't be afraid
to stash Tayson but honestly Juwan
Johnson was actually the guy that was
standing out a little bit uh last week
with the Saints having those High
targets and taysom he's really freaking
good at what he does which is get those
direct snaps and just be a bulldozer uh
you know when he's getting that ball and
just rushing it but we can't rely on
that week to week take some hell right
now someone I'm fine usually leaving on
the waiver wire but speaking of tight
ends let's go ahead and talk about
Dawson Knox here it was disappointing
and I mentioned him a little bit with
the Gerald Everett discussion that we
just had good usage not great usage 86
snaps 66 routes was only targeted on
eight percent of his routes he still got
Josh Allen under Center and kind of lost
in the opening night hoopla was that
contract extension that got announced
shortly before Thursday Night Football
four years 52 million with 31 million
guaranteed for Dawson Knox so one of the
reasons why people got off the Austin
Knox a little bit during the off season
was the idea that you know week one two
touchdown hero OJ Howard who actually
started the off-season on the bills
could make it just a little bit more of
a committee but that's not the case at
all Tommy Sweeney gets a few snaps here
or there Dawson Knox is the full-time
starter in this offense it was just a
dumb week so no I don't think the Austin
Knox deserves to be ranked with the
Durham wallers of the world or anything
like that but you start going around the
League's tight end situations and you're
going to have a tough time needing more
than one hand to rank the amount of guys
ahead of Dawson Knox so this week I do
just barely need two hands I have them
as my tight end eight and Zach ERS is
going to once again enter the weekend
questionable I'll move up Knox to tight
on seven I would not play them you know
ahead of guys like God or Hawkinson but
give me Knox over Schultz over
friarmouth over even you know
probably over Albert o as well I just
think the Josh Allen factor is too great
to ignore here with Dawson Knox
from M coton 0.5 PPR AJ Dillon or Josh
Jacobs this is a close one guys I'm
gonna give Josh Jacobs
okay I'm going AJ Dylan for now we could
go with Josh Jacobs so there's a small
thing going on with the Raiders Brandon
Bolton they're passed down back has a
hamstring injury and he has not been
practicing this week so what have I been
saying we don't like the three back
committees Brandon Bolton's out of the
picture all of a sudden Josh Jacobs
actually has a chance to start getting
some of those targets that we're really
hoping will go his way he can do it he
just never really gets him they use bold
and they have a mirror Abdullah there
they've used Kenyan Drake in the past
even though he's not on the team now
it's just a workload issue so right now
AJ Dylan but if Brandon Bolden gets
ruled out don't be afraid to get Josh
Jacobs in there that's a good problem to
have those are two quality low end rb2s
from Darius Whitson Zeke or corduro
Patterson into Flex gonna be Cordero
Patterson for me Damien Williams
suffered that rib injury he started off
the week without practicing leaving
Cordero Patterson to once again be the
featured early down back and the pass
down back as we already know he had in
his repertoire so Falcons offense maybe
just a little bit better than we think
and cpat just looked fantastic out there
in week one so he and Kareem hunt were
always you know those two running acts
that we told you guys before a season
started we're just egregiously mispriced
going around eight or nine in A lot of
these drafts so very happy to see both
those guys return plenty of value early
unfortunately it was Zeke he's splitting
the backfield with Tony Pollard at least
according to the week one usage and when
you remove that scoring upside that Dak
Prescott brings to the table awfully
difficult to get behind Zeke here in a
game that could feature the Cowboys
trailing against the Bengals
from Greenberg Ben is Mike Williams
viable versus the Chiefs or do we ride
Christian Kirk two good options I really
like what I saw at a Christian Kirk last
week he was getting separation at will
out of the slot and also was being used
downfield that nice 40-yard catch he had
deep was fantastic and he honestly like
after that found his way into the end
zone just barely stepped out of Bounds
at the three yard line so I like both
these guys but we got to go with Mike
Williams man he's actually played now
four games without Keenan Allen over the
years six catches 61 yards four catches
54 yards okay good not great but 108
yards in a touchdown in 109 yards and
two touchdowns and four appearances with
Keenan Allen either sidelined or out for
the majority of the game so it's Justin
Herbert they're playing the Chiefs it's
gonna be a shootout let's go ahead and
get the number one wide receiver that
again the Chargers are paying 60 million
dollars to go out there and have a
better week too than he did week one
speaking of other players that I'm not
worried about moving forward Aaron
Rodgers let's put in the context exactly
what happened there in week one no David
backyardi they're starting left tackle
out with a knee injury no no Elkton
Jenkins they're starting right tackle he
was out with a knee and a Peck injury
and presume number one wide receiver
al-mazard also out with an ankle injury
how many quarterbacks around the league
could actually look good without their
starting tackles or without their number
one wide receiver maybe Mahomes pulls it
off because again the guy's an alien but
you guys get the point Rogers was not
set up for Success last week and what
happened the first play of the game he
threw one of the best passes of the week
right into Christian Watson's Bread
Basket drop should have been a 75-yard
touchdown it wasn't they went on to have
a tough time handling you know Daniel
Hunter and zadarius Smith at the line of
scrimmage so for me I'm going to write
this one off we saw what happened last
year when the Packers played in week one
against the Saints they looked even
worse and that was with Devonte Autumn
so now he gets Chicago Bears defense
that Ash Rogers told us he owns them and
he really has ever since Matt leflore
got to the sir are coaching the Packers
so three years ago Rogers hasn't thrown
a single pick against his defense 16
touchdowns no interceptions against the
Bears since Matt leflore took over
absolute Madness so Aaron Rodgers you
know don't get overly carried away I'm
not expecting him to be this top five
quarterback uh throughout the season or
anything we still got to realize that
he's not going to be having the same
sort of rushing upside as guys like
Lamar you know Jalen hurts even someone
like Trey Lance but still firmly firmly
firmly at the top of that Matthew
Stafford cousin's car tier of pocket
passes that we see populating that qb1
borderline
from the chat beard Brody Jamal Williams
is he worth an rb2 or Flex or bench him
so DeAndre Swift has been banged up this
week he didn't practice today but he's
gone come out and said already that he's
not worried about the ankle injury Jamal
Williams is what I like to call it Flex
whip benefits we do have instances where
in week one got two rushing touchdowns
that was fantastic you know before the
season I said that Jamal has a chance to
be this year's James Connor but last
year James Connor before Chase Edmonds
got injured he was a bit of a touchdown
or bus type of running back so Jamal
Williams someone that I don't think you
need to force him to the starting lineup
by any stretch of the imagination right
now but once bye weeks start happening
he's a great guy to have on the bench
and God forbid Swift does Miss time with
this injury or something else all of a
sudden you're gonna see Jamal Williams
on the cover of every single wave of
wire article
from T Warren Penny Robinson Renfro or
Palmer at the flex I'm going to lean
Hunter Renfro just barely here where
shop penny is tough to get behind him
with uh Kenneth Walker confirmed to be
back at least According to Pete Carroll
as much as we can trust Pete Allen
Robinson is someone that we shouldn't be
Robinson versus Hunter Renfro is tough I
do lean Renfro because I think Robinson
is going to potentially have to deal
with a shadow date from AJ Terrell we
saw Terrell Shadow Mike Thomas last
weekend it didn't go well Michael Thomas
scored two touchdowns I think we've seen
enough from AJ Terrell though to know
that he's still going to be pretty tough
for just about anyone to overcome and
because he doesn't move in the slot I do
think that he is going to match up on
Robinson so this is actually a good
example of using matchups more so as a
tie breaker I have Robinson and a hunter
Renford rank very close to each other
I'm gonna give Renfrow the slight nod
just by virtue of him not having to deal
with such a tough matchup and I also
like the overall scoring potential in
that Raiders game more so than what
we're going to see with the Rams and
Falcons
from Evan Q Judy or Henderson at the
flex that's a very tough one because
Henderson man if he keeps that sort of
usage that we saw last week going
forward he's gonna be impossible to
bench and for right now I'm gonna go
ahead and sue me has that usage give me
Daryl Henderson it's a great problem to
have I mean we're talking about a top 18
running back and a top 18 wide receiver
so maybe Evan you need to get out of
that 16 League you're in and actually
join you know a 12 or no I'm just
playing man that's a great job drafting
but truly with Henderson you know your
favorite fantasy analyst favorite
sleeper I can guarantee it you know is
one of the more obvious picks out there
the entire offseason and it's worked out
like with Henderson I don't think anyone
assumed this but talking about Sean
McVay one of the only coaches that's
been willing to lead their starting
running backs out there for 80 90 snaps
out of time and that's what happened
with Henderson no running back was more
involved in terms of just a route for
dropback basis than Henderson in week
one only saquon Barkley played a higher
percentage of their team's offensive
snaps than Daryl Henderson could have
changed with Cam makers yes but
expecting that to swing all the way back
to acres might be wishful thinking so
Daryl Henderson he's someone that's
going to be awfully difficult to take
out the starting lineup until we see
otherwise with Cam makers getting out of
that Sean McVay doghouse
Mike Williams guys mentioned it before
but please get him in starting lineups
of all shapes and sizes you cannot show
me a starting lineup even in these four
six team leagues whatever you cannot
show me a starting lineup That should
have Mike Williams benched if you do you
have freaking three or four top 10 wide
receivers and obviously have a pretty
good problem but chill this is nothing
new he's Mr Boomer bust but when the bus
come there's usually a Boom coming back
coming after so last week was a bust
what'd he do in week 18 against the
Raiders nine catches 119 yards and a
touchdown everyone basically busted on
the charges last week because Justin
Herbert had to go you know all
socialists on us and he did not give any
single player more than four targets
spreading it out great for chargers they
got the win it's smart move from Justin
Herbert he's a fantastic real-life
quarterback and fantasy quarterback he
just didn't overly feed anyone last week
because he didn't have to I'm not so
sure that's going to be the case ahead
of a likely shootout here against the
Chiefs weak High 54 point game total
like again Mike Williams we have this
bad thought in our head here about oh he
just busted you know why am I going to
go back to the well here if you just
remove that if you said okay I have
Justin Herbert's number one wide
receiver Keenan Allen's out we're in an
absolute shootout here start Mike
Williams don't even think twice about it
get him in starting lineups of all
shapes and sizes
from Big House Bateman or Claypool and
PPR I'm going Bateman it is close though
guys you know looking at the Miami
matchup Gabe Lamar all kinds of problems
against the blitz last year and that
really has been a consistent issue with
Lamar over the past two seasons maybe
it's Greg Roman's fault for not
adjusting maybe it's Lamar not having
enough pass game options just to defeat
the blitz with I am the opposite of a
Lamar slanderer I love that guy I hope
he throws 500 yards and five touchdowns
this week he's been objectively bad
against the blitz though bottom five and
PFF passing grade QB rating yards per
attempt whatever stat you want to throw
out there he has not been good against
the Blitz and Rashad Bateman could be
someone that unfortunately isn't able to
have the usual ceiling that we're hoping
for with him as the Undisputed wide
receiver won this offense with that said
Chase Claypool still very much involved
in the wide receiver committee situation
I don't expect him to be working that
far ahead at George Pickens each and
every week and Deontay Johnson Remains
the overall wide receiver one alpha in
Pittsburgh 30 Target share even with
ubisky under Center you guys saw that
freaking Jumpman grabbing made on the
sideline just the true talent and it's
gonna be tough for Claypool to overtake
him at any point this season
from Corey B chaotic is Alan Robinson
invisible or do you think he will
actually get targets like I keep
Robinson on your team but this week you
heard me before with the Renfro question
I'm not giving him the tiebreaker I
would really like to see it first before
we're going to go back to the well here
because that was just brutal and we saw
Matthew Stafford just more than willing
to feed not only Cooper cup but also
Tyler Higby well ahead of Robinson
throughout the afternoon so Robinson I'm
not you know the Rams gave him over 30
million dollars I don't think they did
that to be a decoy we don't only have to
go back last year you know and look at
what Robert Woods did over the first
couple weeks of the year to find the
last time that we maybe overreacted to a
brief dry spell from the Rams number two
wide receiver I'm more so concerned that
this week the Rams 10 point favorites
over the Falcons I'm not so sure they're
gonna have to keep their foot on the gas
and catching that AJ Terrell Shadow the
dude just gave up two Tellies to Michael
Thomas maybe that lit a fire under him I
just think this is going to be a tough
one for Robinson to really break out
another player guys that I am just not
worried about moving forward is going to
be Philadelphia Eagles wide receiver
Devonte Smith because his usage was just
fine unfortunately he just didn't get
the ball former number three overall
pick Jeffrey okuta was able to clamp him
down great job by akuda but it's one of
those things where it's tough to give
too much credit to akuda and the Lion's
defense for shutting down Devante Smith
because why would Jalen hurts go
anywhere else with the ball AJ Brown was
freaking Unstoppable but the Eagles
still firmly view this I believe as a
1a1b situation last week Devonte Smith
actually ran more routes than AJ Brown
just one more but they are right there
at the top and they're going to
consistently be Jalen hurts top two pass
game options and for me the bigger
takeaway in Philly was the fact that
this isn't going to be the most
run-heavy offense in the league like it
was from weeks eight through eight eight
weeks eight through 18 last season they
actually had a pass play rate of just
46.8 percent during that stretch and had
gone to the playoffs credit to Nick
siriani Jalen hurts was running miles
Sanders they brought Jordan Howard back
they were winning football games and it
worked but they went out they traded the
first round pick for AJ Brown and that
46.8 pass play rate last week 58.3 in a
game that they got a huge lead on only
really had to worry about the Lions deep
into the fourth quarter so for me now
looking at this week two point favorites
against the Vikings 50.5 Point um over
under I think there's a much better
chance we see the Eagles forced to
really pass to keep up in this one and
for that reason I have Devonte Smith as
my wide receiver 35 ahead of Renfro
Cooper ayok and Josh Palmer among others
very similar sentiment with our next
wide receiver guys Adam thielen once
again the routes they were all there
Justin Jefferson Adam thielen they both
ran 33 routes obviously Jefferson was
the one making the most out of it and
why wouldn't he the Packers refused to
put jair Alexander on him and they
seemingly refused to put anyone on him
half the time I mean the fact he was so
wide open on those deep crossers just
Madness to watch but looking back again
we'd have more than the one game sample
size of these two together going back to
when Jefferson actually joined the
Vikings in 2020 in the first place guys
both thielen and Justin Jefferson have
nine top eight weekly fantasy finishes
and four ppro scoring since 2020. here
are the only wide receivers with more
receiving touchdowns than Adam thielen
since 2020. Devonte Adams and Mike Evans
that's it when Adam thielman is healthy
he needs to be in your starting lineup
that's why we drafted him I know the
week one does unfortunate but once again
let's use the multiple years of evidence
we have that Adam thielen is one of the
best touchdown scorers at the position
not one week one done but where yeah
cousins just kept going to Jefferson why
wouldn't he same sentiment with Joan
Hurst and AJ Brown looking at Devonte
Smith so once again guys like Devonte
guys like Dylan even Allen Robinson
after this tough matchup let's not get
off them like we did Robert Woods last
year as we remember Woods really tough
first part of the Season went on to be
the wide receiver 12 before injury
though so
keep the questions going chat just want
to help those starting lineups win a
fantasy football championship winning a
game in week two certainly a good way to
start that so QC Gamecock Melvin Gordon
or Travis etn that's a very close one
man I actually gotta check my ranks to
see who I have ahead but I have etn two
spots ahead of Gordon more so because
I'm more confident etn just getting that
passed on work we saw Javonte just get
fed those targets last week and that's
really what saved his game here in
fantasy football historically one target
for a running back is we're 2.7 expected
PPR points that Carrie is just one so
really It's just tough for running backs
that don't have that pass game role to
keep up I know etn dropped the
three-yard touchdown pass he was also
open for a 15-yarder and the guy
averaged 10 yards per touch looked
explosive as hell out there I still
think we'll see bigger days in the
future from uh
from Travis etn so guys more questions
ahead let's jump into personalized
fantasy advice presented by State Farm
where the personal price plan is all
about creating a price just for you
mentioned before with etn I do have
Robinson a couple spots ahead of him
again though this is like our kind of
worst case scenario if you drafted etn
early because of how healthy Robinson is
but we still have an explosive pass
catcher in an offense I think could be a
little bit better than we saw in week
one of Trevor Lawrence starts playing as
well as a lot of people think you can
which three players would I fade ahead
of week two well I'm so happy you asked
I do think that there's a situation
where just guys that we cannot get
behind at all Kadarius Tony with a
Giants seven snaps last week can't do it
won't do it we need to wait to see him
get out of that Giant's dog house before
we move forward also gotta keep an eye
on the weather in the San Francisco game
as we saw last week in that Soldier
Field oh my gosh that pit of just rained
I have never seen a football field look
the way it did by the time that fourth
quarter came around just with rain
everywhere but unfortunately it's gonna
be really muddy again in San Francisco
uh this weekend so as much as I would
love to have the bounce back Trey land
spot which he could get to he still
showed off that rushing upside last week
I would keep an eye on that weather in
San Francisco and even at Lambeau on
Sunday night both situations where I
think those teams might be able to Coast
with a run makes me nervous about guys
like Brandon irecon like Alan Lazard
from D Moore Juju or Chris olave gotta
go with YouTube guys we spent all off
season talking about who could be this
year's Cooper cup and JuJu is still
firmly in that conversation six catches
last week all in the first half he
looked healthy and I was a skeptical of
Future's ability to really come back
after just how bad really the last few
years in Pittsburgh were even mostly in
2020 but I think we can put a lot of
that into the Ben Roethlisberger
experience in the later parts of his
career so juja Smith Schuster someone
that I have ranked as a top 30 wide
receiver Crystal Ave unfortunately right
now looks like the number three Target
in New Orleans so I think we'll see some
bigger days ahead for a lobby but Juju
really should be in most fantasy lineups
here across the board
D3 boys hell yeah Mal's a D3 linebacker
back in the day gotta love the D3 boys
Datsun or Boyd or Michael Carter so it's
Boyd ft Higgins is out with that
concussion Higgins was limited on
Wednesday he seems to be progressing
through the protocol with that said he
did miss practice on Thursday due to
personal issues so in those games that
we have actually seen Higgins Miss over
the years or Jamar Chase just not being
on the Bengals yet but Joe Burrows under
Center Tyler Boyd in 13 of these games
he's averaged 6.6 receptions for 69
yards and .4 touchdowns so Tyler Boyd is
one of these classic wide receiver
threes who you don't love but you can
put them in the flex more weeks than not
but if anything happens to Chase or
Higgins as it's happening boy needs to
be in almost all starting lineups if
Higgins does play though give me Michael
Carter ahead of Jahan Dotson just a
little crowded in Washington and as much
as I do think that Carson Wentz is can
be average or below average as opposed
to horrific which a lot of people have
kind of been uh setting the expectation
for him it is going to be somewhat
crowded in Washington I don't think
we're gonna see each of maclaurin Curtis
Samuel and Dotson scoring like they all
happened to last week
from Dave Blue's cards Juju or Christian
Kirk in the flex man I have him ranked
right next to each other I'm giving Juju
just the bear the edge here and this
comes down to I think their target
distribution is pretty equal I think
both guys are good players at this point
I would honestly give the edge to
Christian Kirk from a pure talent
perspective based on what we saw in week
one he just looked very explosive out
there but Patrick Mahomes versus Trevor
Lawrence that's where I give the edge to
Juju give me Juju in that conversation
from GRS demigod Tara mcclorn or a
Monroe Saint Brown wide receiver too
it's a Monroe guys I've finally done it
a Monroe Saint Brown is a wide receiver
one what more does he need to do now
it's six of his last seven games he's
posted wide receiver one numbers he's
caught at least six passes in all of
these games I think it's actually eight
passes in all of these games he's Jared
goff's new Cooper cup it's what's
happening I don't know how many times we
need to see it happen before we continue
cheating on manra as the sun god that he
really is so Monroe Saint Brown
especially in full PPR scoring you don't
take him out of the starting lineup even
if there's fire
from coyote DJ Moore bound to bounce
back yeah more so than last week but we
have seen now in three seasons with DJ
Moore and Robbie Anderson together in
2020 it was actually a situation where
Robbie out targeted DJ over the course
of the entire year DJ I do believe
actually outscored him when it was all
said and done bit more explosive but
that version of the mount rule offense
was happy to feature Robbie ahead of DJ
last year went back to DJ this year at
least for one week it was a Robbie so I
think Robbie as one of the biggest
risers of the week from someone that we
don't care about and now he's more of a
wide receiver five Boomer bus type I do
think that we could see a disparity
shrink as the season goes on with that
said DJ Moore still my wide receiver 23.
I'm playing him ahead of guys like Juju
Metcalf Kirk Elijah Moore amongst others
from omargani Elijah Moore or Devante
Smith I am going with Elijah Moore this
week guys if we look at what Elijah
Moore has done in three games with Joe
Flacco under center it's been fantastic
and it's actually one of my favorite uh
just blow up spots of the week here for
Elijah because Joe Flacco came in late
into a game last year what happened
after that two of his three pass
attempts were completed to Elijah Moore
for a touchdown the next game Elijah
Moore goes for eight catches 141 yards
and a touchdown against the Dolphins
last week five catches 49 yards he did
catch a touchdown though that was
nullified because of offensive pass
interference yes it was offensive pass
interference Elijah Moore basically
shoved the guy down it should have been
called with that said though guys now
three games where Flacco has managed to
get Eli the ball very often I think in
this game against the Browns even if the
Jets don't want to pass as much as they
did in week one which was the second
highest rate in the league I'm not so
sure they're going to be able to run the
ball the Browns held Christian McCaffrey
and Company to minus 0.1 yards before
contact per carry like they could not
run the ball ball against miles Garrett
and Company so Denzel Ward does not
Shadow I think Elijah Moore could have
10 to 12 Targets this week and make the
most out of it because he's freaking
Elijah Moore and really good at football
from C McElroy Aaron Jones or AJ Dylan
he has them both don't be afraid to
start both of them this is maybe the
only backfield in the league that we can
say that about but Aaron Jones is my
rb14 AJ Dillons my rb21 we already saw
Matt leflore come out and say only eight
Touches for Aaron Jones is unacceptable
I think this is one of these instances
where it was a dud week bad week and
just like it was last year in week one
for the Packers I'm not gonna put too
much into it but they also asked Matt
leflore you know earlier in August is
it's a 1a1b situation he says a 1a1a
situation so both Dylan and Jones are
capable receivers Jones is better I
think he will separate you know in the
receiving part of the game but even if
he gets more targets it makes sense if
AJ Dylan gets more of the goal line
attempts so every year we see I believe
over the past 10 years has been about
1.7 instance it was 2.3 instances excuse
me of one team enabling multiple top 24
running backs I think the Packers will
certainly be one of those teams when
it's all said and done this year
from oh no Amari Cooper or Tyler Boyd
it's going to be Tyler Boyd for me if
Higgins is out otherwise give me Amari
Cooper if you guys didn't watch that
Browns game you did not see how good
Amari Cooper was I know three catches 17
yards you know Cowboys fans are trying
to take their Victory lapse and do all
that but man he looks as good as ever
really from a route running perspective
in that game three separate times they
cut to the wide receiver cornerback ISO
Cam and you can see Cooper just leaving
whatever poor Defender was on him and
the dust unfortunately the Jacoby
brassette experience wasn't too good he
missed them all three times two of them
Cooper was a pass interfere with so it
kind of you know messed up their timing
to an extent but still I wouldn't be
surprised if we're you know Shish and a
lot with Jacoby under Center throughout
the year also miss Kareem hunt for a
long potential touchdown so for me
Cooper borderline wide receiver three
Pickens is Out Boys ahead of him
otherwise just put Cooper into flex and
realize that we're gonna have some
Jacoby induced bad performances
from Iman Curtis Samuel Over CD this
week absolutely not this is you know
really overreacting to week one see
treat CD lamb like Terry mcclorn like
Brandon Cooks a really talented Target
hog wide receiver one who unfortunately
has to play and a bad offense that's
what we're doing look CD land was still
out there 97 snaps he still had a team
High 11 targets where also the Cowboys
gonna go with the ball in games that
were now not even expecting him to be
able to lead in the first place so there
actually was a moment late in that game
if you guys turned it off you know at
the end of third quarter or whatever you
didn't miss much and I don't blame you
but CD did get wide open deep for a
potential 70-yard touchdown Cooper Rush
missed him unfortunately by just a
couple inches so again just like we said
of a Cooper certainly a possibility that
Cooper Rush is going to make life
difficult for CD more weeks than not but
just think about how this conversation
could be different with CD if he just
had a little bit more accurate pass
there at the end
from dude bra Mikko or Curtis Samuel
this is a situation where I will give
Curtis Samuel the slight Edge one of the
things that Miko benefited from last
week was Justin Watson having to exit
early with a chest injury he's back
though and I think behind Juju and MBS
it's just a muddle group there with
Watson Miko and Sky Moore so just in
terms of pure volume I think Curtis
Samuel could run like twice as many
routes as Michael Hardman this week and
might even get some carries too give me
Curtis there last one everyone
appreciate you guys joining us as always
JC East sell high on Jeff Wilson it just
depends you know there's always the
right price for any of these players out
here but it really does look like he's
going to be the guy I know we've seen
that hot hand Kyle Shanahan quote going
around and a lot of people have
irresponsibly attributed that to the
entire situation no Kyle Shanahan said
behind Jeff Wilson who is his starter
who is the only running back who touched
the ball last week other than Debo if we
want to call him a running back the only
running back to touch the ball and to
get a snap even behind Elijah Mitchell
last week was Jeff Wilson when Kyle
Shanahan said they were going to look at
the hot hand that was between Mason and
Tyrion Davis price so maybe something
happens maybe Jeff Wilson is ineffective
and he loses his job but for this week I
am firing up Jeff Wilson as a borderline
rb2 look it's not a slam dunk because we
have Trey Lance you know being the Dual
threat player that's going to be a
little bit annoying taking some of those
Rush attempts not dunking it down as
much he's gonna be scrambling instead
and we're going to Debo Samuel getting
his fair share of Rush attempts but Jeff
Wilson he's Kyle Shanahan started
running back go back to Mike Shanahan
days this has always been a winning
proposition and for that reason I do
have Jeff Wilson as a recommended start
he's my rb-26 ahead of guys like Clyde
Ed brazilaire James Robinson Damon
Harris or Andre Stevenson Michael Carter
all that and so much more
guys what thank you for tuning in to
another edition of BR fantasy system and
fun we'll be back every Thursday at 5
p.m Eastern throughout the year just
helping you try to go win some fantasy
championships that's what it's all about
after all so I'm Ian Hardis thanks again
for tuning in to be our fantasy
presented by State Farm we'll catch you
later